For this main video
It is worth saying from the outset
The actual objective is clear
Is to achieve happiness
And not misery
But you look like me
You may find advice on happiness
It is kind of problematic
Almost annoying
So it may be helpful to think
On how to achieve the opposite
Thus, to see how that procedure has been
Take action against us
Happiness is the subject that is
Extraordinarily appropriate for this mental reflection
Dear viewers
Do not take the main video as craft advice
I want each of you to find his own happiness
That's why I made this video
Good luck
Why are you still here?
Click the video in the top left corner
Translation: Shuan Hamid @shwan_hamid